hello and welcome to my latest leaders briefing
i'm currently at our offices here at mill lane
in Wingerworth where at the moment we're flying
the Ukrainian flag in solidarity with the people
of Ukraine and i think i speak on behalf
of all of us when i say how shocked and
saddened we are by the ongoing situation over in
Ukraine and how i'm sure all of us will want to
to make it known that we stand with the
people of Ukraine we certainly have at our
recent full council meeting and also as a
council we're looking very closely at the
government's homes for Ukraine scheme at the
moment to see how we can support refugees that are
clearly fleeing such a horrible
horrible situation over there
we i also want to say a huge huge thank you to all
the residents and community groups and businesses
who have been doing so much to support the people
of Ukraine with generous donations of items and
money and all of those sorts of things so i
just want to say a huge thank you for that
and we've been getting some our inquiries
ourselves as a council about how people can
help and we're certainly encouraging people
to go on the disasters emergency committee
website and donate via that means that seems to be
the message that we're getting that donations via
the disasters emergency committee is the best way
that you can get help to the people of Ukraine so
please do continue to do all the amazing things
that you're doing and continue to give generously
to help in this humanitarian crisis moving on to
a bit of different news i'm sure many of you will
have received your Council tax bills through the
post recently it is the budget setting season for
many councils across the country and we've taken
the the difficult decision to increase council tax
by 2.58 percent or our share of the council tax
bill if you like by 2.58 percent and I say it's
a difficult decision because it genuinely is for
all councillors and as an organisation as a whole
we've had to very carefully balance the fact that
clearly our residents are facing increases in the
cost of living and pressures at home and we want
to keep Council tax as low as we possibly can
to be as helpful as possible to our residents
but also we as an organisation are facing some
of those pressures ourselves particularly rising
energy costs inflation and the like and so we've
got to balance those out and we want to make sure
that we continue to provide really first-class
excellent services for the district um so we took
the decision to to to increase by 2.58 as i say
it's below inflation and we hope that residents
will understand our reasons for doing so and that
we can continue to deliver a balanced budget and
excellent services for the district as a result
We've also recently found out the news that Derby
and Derbyshire have been named as a pathfinder
for the government's new county deal scheme now
the government you'll have all heard about the
government referring to the to leveling up as as
being part of its agenda now the government's also
published recently a leveling up white paper which
sets out in much more detail what they really mean
about levelling up and how they want to improve
areas like ours which have have suffered for
for many years with historic under investment
by successive government so this is a real
opportunity for North East Derbyshire and we
want to work with Derbyshire County Council and
derby city council and all of the other borough
and district councils within Derbyshire to help
make sure that we get the best out of that deal
it's there's still a lot of detail to go through
there's lots of negotiations happening with the
government around what that really means for us
but we'll continue to keep residents updated
but we're really excited about it we think it
represents a really good opportunity to level up
in northeast Derbyshire and the wider county so
we'll keep you posted but please keep a lookout
because it's a really exciting time for local
government and for devolution in our area our
cabinet has also just approved a parking strategy
for the district area we're committed to investing
280 000 pounds per year for the next several years
to trying to find solutions to parking issues
particularly where we have large areas of council
housing in the district we know that we've got so
many different areas where parking is a problem
where we've got lots of grassed areas for
example where there's absolutely minimal
parking and residents find it really frustrating
that they just can't get parking spaces near to
where they live so we're really keen to try
and address some of those issues and that's
what our parking strategy is seeking to do
moving on again the District Council has also
announced now that it's going to increase
the fines for fly tipping and littering
to the maximum amount that we're able to do so
within the legislation now we've always wanted
to take a really tough stance against fly tipping
and littering because we know how important it is
to communities and how much of a blight it is
on our beautiful rural countryside surroundings
so we think that this is part of a wider package
of measures we're trying to introduce to really
crack down on fly tipping it happens far too
often there's absolutely no excuse for fly
tipping or littering in this district and we want
to send a really loud and clear message to anyone
thinking about doing that that it's absolutely not
acceptable we have also crushed a car a few months
ago that was involved in in flight tipping and
again we hope that that's sending the that really
clear message that it's just not acceptable to fly
tip your your rubbish in North East Derbyshire and
we'll continue reviewing measures wherever we can
to ensure that we're taking the toughest possible
stance against that and increasing those fines is
just part of that and I think it's a really good
thing that we've done there now keeping with the
theme of keeping our district looking beautiful
we're also supporting the Great
British Spring Clean initiative
this year we do it every year and basically
the Great British Spring Clean encourages
all residents from across the country to do their
bit to help do some litter picking in their local
community and help tidy it up really we we
do it every year as I say and our refuse team
are able to provide all the kit litter pickers
bags uh the hoops to hold the bags in hi-vis
jackets all the works that you'll need to do it we
have a lot of fantastic volunteer litter picking
groups already in the district but we're always
keen to encourage more people to get involved
i'll certainly be doing it at some stage this
spring as well and i think it's a really important
year to do it in particularly with the the
Platinum Jubilee so i think if you can if
you can do it if you're interested let's all get
together and help clean for The Queen now moving
back to the theme of the the energy crisis
and the cost of living crisis at the moment
many of you will have heard about the government's
plans for the 150 pound rebate on council
tax there's lots more information on our
website about that and you can find out
whether you're whether you're eligible we will
be making payments to all those who are eligible
over the coming weeks there isn't any need to
contact us or to apply for anything if you're
eligible you that you will receive the payment but
as I say there is more information on the website
if you want to find out a bit more about how that
will work in practice now you may remember that
last year we held a couple of meet the council
events where we myself and some of my colleagues
and several council officers from across the
different departments within the district council
came to a few local areas within the district and
offered to meet with their residents and talk to
them about the services that we provide and talk
to them about our plans for moving the district
forward i'm really pleased to say that we've
got a couple more events coming up in the next
few weeks we have one in one in Shirland coming
up in April and then again we're going to Barlow
in May the details will be on the screen but
please do come along to those events if you're in
the area and you want to find out more about what
the what the district council offers and our plans
for taking the district forward moving forward we
do want to speak to you we want to be a listening
council we want to make sure that the things
that we do back in these buildings here reflect
what residents priorities are so it's a great
opportunity for you to come and ask us any
questions find out more about what we do and and
give your views on how we can how we can continue
to improve our services finally as i said earlier
we all know it's the Queen's Platinum Jubilee
this year and i'm sure many of you across the
district will be celebrating and rightly so now
we want to support the district to make all of
those events as successful as they possibly can
can be so we're asking a few things if you're
interested in holding an event and you want to
do a street closure please get in touch with us we
have waived the fees this year for street closures
for events related to the Platinum Jubilee so
please do get in touch and find out more on
the website about how to do that we also have
some grants available for anyone who's wanting
to host some events or do something specific
to help commemorate the the Platinum Jubilee
so again there's more information on our website
about our community action grants to support
that sort of activity and finally we also
want to support the district by advertising
and publicizing all the different events that
are happening around the district over the over
the course of this year and in particular on
the on the Platinum Jubilee weekend so if you
are having an event please do get in touch with us
tell us about it and give us the details and we'll
obviously then share that to a wider audience as
much as possible so that everyone can get involved
and have a great great great event and great year
celebrating this absolutely monumental achievement
from from her majesty the queen well thanks very
much for watching this latest edition of the
the leaders briefing I really hope you found
the updates useful please do continue to keep
a lookout on our social media channels and on
our website for more news and information as
it arises and i look forward to seeing you again
in a month or so's time with some more good news